nicole's with us in augusta maine
hey nicole how are you hi i'm good thank
you so much for taking my call
sure what's up um so me and my husband
are on baby steps three i believe so
we're definitely the size of the house
and
we're working towards our emergency fund
we have eight thousand in place right
now
great and after that thank you and after
that we want to buy a car
good and he got a situation to me and
i've heard you talk about it on the show
to stay away from it so kind of just
wanted you to help me walk through the
situation
he said that we would like to save up
to lease a car so instead of paying
monthly you can just put it all down
in the beginning for the three years um
so he was looking at
a 2021 ram um with 380 a month
so that i'd be like 13 000 paying that
upfront
and then the buyout would be 2300 or 23
000 and in that three years of having it
saving up that 23 000 to pay it off
um and i just wasn't sure how to go
about that i've heard you talk about
leasing cars as the most expensive way
to drive a car
it is they just wanted your advice it is
and the most expensive car
ever is a brand new one the worst car
accidents happen on the showroom floor
so when he drives that beautiful
fabulous pickup off the showroom floor
he's going to lose ten thousand dollars
that day
that's what i was um thinking because
his argument
was his argument is he wants a truck
and he's willing to he's willing to
overlook any amount of mathematics in
order to buy a truck
he thinks that he'll be actually getting
it for less
because it'd be 23. that's because he's
not good at math
and um and so let me help you with this
if you take 13 000 over to hertz
and pre-pay your rental payment they'll
let you drive a hertz car for a long
time too
and if you add up thirteen thousand
dollars and twenty four thousand dollars
and you figure out what you're actually
paying for this dodge ram when it's all
said and done
it is more than you would have paid for
it had you walked in there and laid
benjamin's on the table
because it wouldn't be until three years
later i know
listen let me ask you something do you
really think
that chrysler is stupid
no and that's why i was calling you
because i was i was like this
guy your husband has not found the one
time that chrysler made a mistake
right like they've got to be making
money on this something yeah
it's not like you found a loophole so he
didn't find a loophole when you add it
up
the actual cost on a lease averages 14
cost of capital it's like borrowing
money at 14
interest and the value of this car plus
this car is going to go down in value
rapidly because he's buying a brand new
car and you all aren't millionaires
no we're not so you should not be buying
a brand new car and taking that kind of
a hit and loss and value until you're
millionaires
you can't afford to lose this much so
boy's got boy's got truck fever he needs
cold showers what he needs
yeah and um so my other question when we
do go to buy a car
i know you say don't you know spend it
on or
buy it that's more than 50 percent of
your all your cars added together
oh all your are all your cars added
together okay
that's good to know i didn't know that
and what is the annual income of both of
us yeah your household income what's
your what's your household income the
two of you added together
well right now i'm going to full-time
school so my income is very like hit or
miss
and um his is 70 000. and he is getting
a pay raise in september but only like
500
a month okay so he makes 76 thousand
dollars
and what are you know so you don't want
all of your cars to be worth more than
about 35 40 000 bucks
and the only the only reason is is that
i love cars i don't know i'm not against
you having a decent car i'm against the
car owning you
if you've got 80 000 worth of cars and
you make 80 000 a year you have so much
tied up in things that are going
backward that you can't build wealth
definitely yeah i was definitely
hesitant on the situation
but didn't really know how to
work it out to me you know to kind of
say okay this is a bad idea
um oh it's definitely a bad idea
so you start with the premise that
chrysler's not stupid and they're not
going to lose money
if you haven't figured out how they're
making money that doesn't mean they're
not
it just means you haven't figured it out
that's all it means because listen if
you turn that car back
in that car has to sell for more than 24
000 at the time you turn it back in
they're gonna lose money
they don't lose money yeah they've got
thousands and thousands of dodge rams on
the road and they have
lots of statistical evidence of exactly
what that puppy's going to be worth at
the end of this lease
a closed-in lease the residual value the
buyout at the end of the lease
is is a statistical analysis it's an
actuarial table these guys
do not screw these things up if they do
they lose
millions and millions and millions of
dollars because it didn't just happen on
your car it happened on all of them like
your car
yes so is the buyout based like
calculated to what they estimate it to
be in the three years
no the buyout is what they they estimate
it to be
uh more that slightly more than the car
is worth
oh at the time at that time they're
estimating if
you got a twenty four thousand dollar
buyout at the end of the lease they're
estimating that car is gonna be worth
somewhat less than
twenty four thousand dollars okay yeah
that's what i was kind of thinking um
i think another person's argument and
the situation that we're talking about
was that somebody just bought like a
2018 like chevy for 35 40 000
in 2015 so they were like trucks really
hold their value
oh crap you are
you are listening to a whole lot of
broke people with truck fever
listen i drove a raptor i didn't drive
it today i got a raptor in the garage i
drove it yesterday i like big trucks i
i like you know i don't own a single car
with a horsepower less than 400
horsepower
so um i like cars i like stuff that goes
with zoom zoom
but they all go down in value that
you're getting screwed on all of them
financially when you buy them they're
all they
all suck this idea that you know they
hold their value
yeah just visit one that's three or four
years old and then laugh about that
stupid butt statement
that's just ridiculous hold their value
by their fingernails for 20 seconds
maybe
yeah i mean look people i've heard this
before i've heard people hit you with
these scenarios before it's like they
think they've got it figured out
well i mean i actually when i first got
on the radio and there's a guy's a
christian guy
in another part of town that called up
and he was all offended because he owned
one of the
car dealerships and i was telling people
leasing cars rip
off and they're ripping people off he
goes well i'm a christian i'm not
ripping people off and i go yeah you are
and he wanted to he went to come sit
down talk to me and after two hours of
going through the math with him
i said show me one time where you're not
making more money leasing the car
than you are selling the car show me one
time and i'll shut up and he couldn't
find a single one well as christians we
ought to agree and i'm like oh
christians ought to be able to do math
bubba
you know this is a thing you know it's
not it's not a christian damn and jesus
doesn't hate you
for leasing a car that's not the point
um
i mean i mean he probably yeah
yeah bad bad dad jokes are running
through my mind about being all in one
accord but anyway
yeah so yeah so yeah you just it's
but yeah it's just dumb it's just dumb
don't do it